Honestly, for much of the last decade,...
...I thought libraries were extremely boring places,...
...and my opinion of bookstores was only slightly better.
I just think circumstances played a big role.
I felt forced to be there for school projects, for example.
Maybe I was just a spazzy teenager, but you know what?
I've realized that not all bookstores and libraries were created equal.
So, I decided to take a trip to La Biblioteca Vasconcelos...
...here in Mexico City.
It's pretty well-known here, and you're about to find out why.
All right, that's the building right there.
It's pretty big.
Holy smokes!
Oh my god!
This is craziness!
Look at this!
Look at that!
What the... oh my god!
I'm like in shock right now; this is insane!
Don't focus on me.
All right.
I'm just gonna skedaddle out of the frame.
See you guys later.
God!
It continues!
Check this out.
I came from over there.
That's, like, where I entered.
It continues on this side.
I must seem like such a typical American right now,...
...just blown away by everything.